- Canar saying, "Do you think just
"because I'm shy, I can't make it?"
Canar, so obviously shy.
- Do you know what, Canar?
I think I said this, and I think lots
of great entrepreneurs are introverts.
I think, you know, shy's
a relative term, isn't it?
'Cause I've known really shy people
who have become a business owner,
and they've been hugely successful,
and, as time goes by,
they grow in confidence.
Their shyness sort of disappears.
I think you never, you never, ever
get carried away with your own P.R.
You always keep your feet on the ground,
you always keep that
great sense of humility,
and you really want to
be true to your idea
and the purpose that you're pursuing.
So I think, Canar, honestly, I think
in this area, actually,
shyness can be quite a virtue,
and I think with all these things,
if you are feeling particularly shy.
Actually, another example.
When you go up to these kind
of meetups and stuff like that,
Evan, I will tell ya now, I go
and do loads of talks and stuff like that,
if someone comes over to talk to me,
I will allows talk to them.
So, if you're at a meetup,
and you want to kind of
zone in on one person,
get loose in your head saying,
"That person wants to meet me today."
And walk up to 'em and
just introduce yourself,
and you lose nothing.
Even if you're going to
never see that person again,
you lose nothing, but
every time you do that,
you lose a bit of your shyness,
and you gain a bit more
of your confidence,
and I would advocate all
the great entrepreneurs
you and I follow, they're
all super nice guys.
They really are nice guys and gals,
and fundamentally they all started
where you're probably starting today,
and the good guys never
forget where they came from.
In reality, we never
forget where we came from.
We all started as aspiring
entrepreneurs with a dream,
with an idea and an ambition,
and some of us kind of got lucky
and the cards played in our favor,
but we're never, ever,
ever in reality lost
that sense shyness, and I think, Evan,
he looks like an amazing extrovert,
but again, I'm sure in
his past had moments
of shyness or lacking in confidence.
I certainly did.
I've been to places where I've been afraid
to go up and introduce myself to someone,
and sometimes it sort of
either a little friend
on my shoulder, or
someone in my inner self
just kicks me to say, "Go
on, introduce yourself."
Don't feel any shame,
just go up and overcome,
and then, the more you do
it, the more you practice,
the more confident you become,
and, you know, Canar,
you might be the next
Tony Robbins or something like that.
Within you, all these guys
who go and do Ted Talks
and all these sort of things,
if you look back at those
guys 10, 20, 30 years ago,
they all started as
someone who was pretty shy,
someone who probably lacked confidence,
and any of those people could be you.